[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael
rosenbalm you like when I say bals I do
I know that's how you say it but you put
an inflection on it that is silly it's
Michael Rosen Bal how's that Michael
Rosen Bal well that's the real
expression of it sounds like you're
doing a soundtrack for a
porn great now I I guarantee Jason just
put porn music on there thanks Jason I
know you did that you're smiling cuz you
did it uh thanks for being here on
another glorious Tuesday or whenever
you're listening to your podcast and and
thank you for making this podcast your
choice your choice I mean there's so
many podcasts but you know we've been
around we're not one of those podcasts
that just jumped on the bandwagon we've
been doing this when we had no listeners
and now we have a loyal fan base and uh
my patrons who really support me and
support the podcast they get back to the
podcast to make this podcast possible um
that's Patron pH at T n.com inside of
you and uh join join patreon today
become a a member there's so many perks
look at it you'll have a blast it's a
great family and uh also uh the inside
of you online store you can get cool
stuff like this sweet inside of you
tumbler coffee Tumblr which I use I have
different colors um there's yellow
there's silver there's all sorts of War
colors I was using the one today with a
little um straw no a little d uh oh the
div yeah div yeah yeah yeah I love that
one the yellow the golf one yeah yeah
yeah that's a great one um tons of stuff
small little ship keys that all I sign
Funko Lex Luthor and uh pops uh flash uh
Lex Smith scripts and tons of inside of
you stuff so so get on there in inside
of you online store and get yourself
some nice stuff um and by the way all
this stuff is at my on my Instagram at
the Michel Rosen bomb you just go to my
link tree shake the link tree and uh it
will show you the cons I'm going to that
me and Welling are going to and doing
Smallville nights and everything is on
there U my rosy puppy fresh breath uh
dog breath additive you just add a
little to water tasteless odorless um
it's on there please check it out it's
on Amazon and it really works I love it
I use it on my dogs and so much more on
the link Tree on my
Instagram um Camal Nani mhm this is his
second time on and uh this was recorded
actually
during the um strike strike yeah uh
Kamal is just uh such a great guy and
super talented and always so busy people
always want to work with this guy and
when you know him like I do you know
we're not tight but we're like we're
friends he came over when I had a party
and um I love him I love his wife Emily
I think they're the sweetest Souls out
there and he deserves all the success he
worked hard for it and uh so we we get
into a lot lot of his life and um I
thought it was a really good episode um
also if you want to go to sunspin my
band sunspin do.com support the band
we're trying to make a new album we do
stag itss which are live performances
virtual um we might do one on December
10th or not December 10th February 10th
which is a Saturday at 5:00 pm so I
think we're going to lock that in and
you can go to Suns spin.com for Merch
which I have there's so much cool merch
there these Wicked hats and tumblers
other stuff too so check out sunspin
dcom and without further Ado let's get
into my inside of my buddy cumal nanani
it's my point of view you're listening
to inside of you with Michael Rosen
[Music]
B inside of you with Michael Rosen bomb
was not recorded in front of a live
studio audience back then what you had
to do to get into premises was so you
see like in Weird Science they're just
like we should have a girlfriend let's
make a girl on your computer and then
they just make it and that's it that's
the the premise that's the whole setup
there's no like breaking into a lab
there's no lightning strike or magical
ambulet stories were simpler in the '
80s I mean just getting into it was like
we know you just want to get to it so
let's just do it it was also a different
thing was like now every story has to
every character has to have some like
backstory about why they are the way
they are and it has to be allegorical
yeah yeah exactly everything has to be
thematic and it's also like this bad guy
is not really a bad guy he had a rough
childhood like sometimes I don't care I
just want someone to be really [__]
evil and that's it do you though do you
not want to have some like subtext some
like backstory on the evil guys so you
like at least go okay because usually
they're just bad and I'm not always I
don't always want that I do want it
sometimes but sometimes like you know
it's sort of this thing that became like
you know these horror icons that we grow
up grew up with like um all the big you
know Jason and all those guys who we
love and then at some point yeah Jason's
next to me Freddy's up there you know it
sort of became at some point like well
well well how did they get this way what
happened to him like I ultimately I I
don't really
care well if it's a I guess it's a it's
it's a slasher flick but think about it
what if Michael M
was there a back story to Michael Myers
really yeah I mean sort of he he was in
insane asylum Asylum he's just the shape
he's just evil so I actually like that
backstory cuz they're like no Halloween
the Rob Zombie ones had backstory on him
he had a [__] up childhood whereas in
the original one you know Donald
Pleasant is just like this thing is evil
and that's it and I thought that that
was cool it gives me more you know have
my mind swim around in whereas you know
I think Rob Zombie is a great filmmaker
um he just he does what he does
sometimes feel like I don't need
backstory on all the you know yeah I
agree Brian pain I think had a really
funny bit about about like Darth Vader's
backstory it's like I just want to eat
the ice cream I don't want to know like
what you know the the do we first we
churn the butter or whatever um I think
there's a balance because I think with
some things having a bad guy who's a bad
guy is good but then sometimes I think
this happens with like notes you know we
get notes from Studios and stuff and
it'll always be like well what what's
the bad guy's deal and then you spend
all this time making the bad guy's
[__] deal and then suddenly you're
like yeah focusing on something that was
never really part of your story doesn't
really care about it it's taking away
from moving the action forward yeah I
understand sometimes you just need an
obstacle you just need an antagonist you
know like do you love horror movies yeah
I mean yeah Emily and I are both
hardcore old school since I was a little
kid horror movie fans um and we watch
everything great stuff bad stuff what's
good uh did you see talk to me that just
came I liked it yeah I thought talk to
me was really good it was good yeah it
was totally good um I like the new evil
dead too I Evil Dead Rising you know I
had fun with it yeah I had fun with it
those were Rarities though because there
aren't many good ones it's tough because
I think horror has become very popular
and has become like a money maker and
whenever that happens it was always like
a niche you know and now it's sort of
the only thing that performs in theater
is it's superheroes and horror that
really performs in theater so now
suddenly horror is getting a little
diluted when it used to really just be a
real expression of the filmmaker like
some of the stuff that Wes Craven did
was like you know it really felt like
nobody but him could have made it and
now you watch a lot of the horror movies
that get big where you're like oh I
could the process that sort of dilutes
other movies is now diluting horror
movies so I like when something like
talk to me comes out where it's like oh
clearly these two guys made this [__]
up movie yeah and it's cool that look
it's hard to come up with a really cool
concept something that hasn't been done
and also when you're dealing with the
70s and 80s you're dealing with no
technology really no cell phone so it's
creepier people can't make the call they
can't go online they can't do all the
things so now you're really going well
why didn't he just do that yeah why
didn't he just call them dude I used to
when I used to do a lot of standup I'm
back to doing standup now again but I
used to have a bit about that where it
was like before you go to the horror
movie they have to have like oh no I
dropped my phone in Sprite you know
everyone everyone has to like I forgot
to charge my phone I'm yeah every horror
movie in the First Act had to be like I
don't have any bars like that just be we
have to know that right away so we
exactly yeah it's hard you know like
movies like The Hitcher and stuff much
harder to do now because it used to you
could go to the middle of the country
and there's nothing around and there's
that one guy chasing you what the [__]
do you do and I think I think that sort
of you know mystery and magical nature
of like those weird parts of the country
have kind of gone too with with the
connection and and all that um but you
know you have this poster of Bram
Stoker's Dracula here and do you see
that it's signed by Gary Alman oh my
[__] God I crossed the oceans of time
to find what a great line see what's
great about that movie I had watched it
when I was a kid when it first came out
and I played the video game and I liked
it but I feel like I didn't get it and
then in the video game there's a video
there Bram Stoker's Dracula video game
yeah they thought it was going to be
like this huge Blockbuster thing instead
it's this really [__] weird
idiosyncratic
movie right so they they had a video
game for like it was for the
Genesis and I think they had it for the
Sega CD you
play video games like crazy you still do
it I still do it does Emily hate it
Emily loves it we both play video games
we both watch horror movies we both play
video games we both love it wow we're
playing Zelda right now Zelda yeah it's
great you mean back in the day Zelda
it's there's a new one there's a new
Zelda yeah it's called Uh the tears of
the
Kingdom um how many hours do you spend a
day on your video games it's pretty
limited rarely more than one hour um how
do you really get into a game only with
one hour well that's the thing but like
on Saturday or Sunday we'll do a longer
session so you gotta that's the thing
like Emily's always like you have like a
problem starting games CU you know the
first time you need to do like a
three-hour session to really get into it
otherwise you're just going to be bored
yeah what what are the great games right
now I'm playing well Bridging the horror
and the thing you know they just remade
Resident Evil 4 and Dead Space they like
they look like brand new games and and
uh both both those games are [__]
fantastic are they
scary uh Dead Space is really really
scary um with Resident Evil you know
it's more of an action game and as like
a real I'm getting real nerdy I love
Resident Evil because it was always
about you have three bullets and this
you got to like you are completely
underpowered and then Resident Evil 4
made it an action game and suddenly you
have like a lot of bazookas and shotguns
and suddenly it's an action game and
it's not as scary not as Atmos feric and
at the time I didn't like it cuz I was
like this is not my Resident Evil now
playing it again knowing what it is I
really loved it wow yeah I don't know
how you have time to do anything you're
I mean since we talked last and it was
it's been years but you your career has
just taken off even more it's like well
no it's it's just obvious it's like you
know the the uh Obi-Wan series and
eternals and Chi andales and and getting
nomin nominated and all these
things and it's weird I look at you and
you came over the house like uh a couple
weeks ago or whatever and you just don't
feel now I don't know if you're a
[__] artist or you're really good at
playing I'm cool I'm fine I'm not
stressed but I mean even with the I mean
what how do you are do you stress out do
you freak out do you do you are you
getting the anxiety do you are you
overwhelmed by now being in you know
really up there now with all these
opportunities it's that's an interesting
question I had I I do have anxiety and
it's been an issue for many many years
and it's sort of it was a few years ago
actually where I realized like oh this
is untenable it's too much anxiety and
there was a few things I realized that I
had Associated work with stress and
nerves and anxiety and it had become
like because of standup you know right
before you go to standup and that was
the first work I did you've done Stand
Up N your heart's beating and I used to
smoke you know back then I would just
like smoke four cigarettes and drink a
Red Bull and then go on stage completely
like wired and so up and so I sort of
associated that body feeling with my
work and it was really hard for Emily
and it was really hard for me and it was
really uh my work suffered and I
realized it was right before eternals
actually where I was like this is by far
the biggest thing I've ever done maybe
the biggest thing I'll ever do this is
so important to me but if I'm like
nervous or anxious about this I'm going
to choke the [__] out of it so I need to
relax and so I started seeing a
therapist and learned the ways to like
really sort of let things go and I've
realized that when I'm relaxed I'm
better at my job I'm better at acting
now I'm better at standup I'm a better
husband all that stuff so I've I
meditate every day um and I still have
anxiety and stuff you know but but i'
I've especially those middle of the
night thoughts you know when you wake up
and you're sort of like what is this
thing um I had one last night yeah what
was that I just I you know I don't
remember exactly what happened but I had
one of those dreams where people that I
don't like were still a big part of my
life and dictating what I do and sort of
like it was just and I don't know what
that means but uh it was almost like
they were telling me something yeah and
uh I I don't know but I have I have some
dark dreams I I should write them down
because they're Clyde Barker [__]
sometimes I find at least for me you
know the way I can like interpret my
dreams and I don't I'm not one of those
I don't believe that they tell the
future or anything like that it's just
like to me it's just a snapshot of your
subconscious to me whatever my biggest
clue to what my brain is trying to tell
me is the emotion I associate with the
dream and the emotion I associate with
the people that are in the dream so for
instance for a long time Emily and I you
know we've been married 16 years now we
have a cat she's 15 so she's been what
how old's the cat 15 I mean what's the
name I meant bagel bagel is your cat
yeah now what last name do you use Nani
uh we use Gordon Gordon at the vet Bagel
Gordon Bagel Gordon Bagel Gordon Bagel
Gordon yeah but she's been with us the
whole time and I for a long time if I
had a dream about her being in distress
something happened to her or she's
missing or me worrying about her that
was about my relationship with Emily it
was about some I realized the feelings
associated with that and it always
seemed to coincide with when you know
Emily had and I had an issue we were
dealing with or something so I realized
that it was about that since then you
know more recently she's an older cat
she's had some health problems so now I
had a dream last night that she wasn't
doing well and that now that really is
just about
her inside of you is brought to you by
wry even the Royals being a king or
queen might seem enticing but more often
than not it comes at the expense of
everything else like your freedom your
privacy and sometimes even your head the
creators of Wes even the rich are
bringing you a brand new podcast called
even the Royals where host Brook and
Arisha pull back the curtain on royal
families past and present from all over
the world and they show you the darker
side of what it means to be royalty from
stories about one of the most infamous
Royals in history Marie Antoinette but
everything you know about her is wrong
after she became Queen at just 19 years
old she ended up in a battle with the
French press that started a series of
impossible toel events it's History's
Greatest smear campaign and it had
deadly consequences or what might be the
worst Royal marriage of all time between
King George IV and Caroline of Brunswick
it's a story involving catfishing fake
pregnancies and It All Leads to a
divorce trial where the whole world sat
on the edge of their seats to see how it
would all play out follow even the
Royals on the wry app or wherever you
get your podcasts you can binge even the
Royals ad free right now on wonder plus
inside of you is brought to you by
better help better help online therapy
so many of my friends use this Ryan uses
this this is something that is helping
so many people around the world uh we
talk about mental illness on the podcast
so much and it's a real integral part of
the
podcast better help makes it so easy for
people to get help and talk to someone
uh it's easy to to get on you have to
just fill out hardly like it takes two
minutes to fill out some little
paperwork it's like a questionnaire it's
not paperwork you know and then uh
you're given a therapist if you don't
like your therapist you change your
therapist easy just like that sometimes
you don't like your therapist it doesn't
it's not a right fit you just change it
no charge it's so easy you know a common
misconception about relationships is
that they have to be easy to be right
but sometimes the best ones happen when
both people put in the work to make them
great therapy can be a place to work
through the challenges you face in all
of your relationships whether your
friends work your significant other
yourself or anyone uh you know this
happened with me I had some friends that
were sort of bringing me down and I
didn't realize it and through therapy I
realized wait a minute this isn't good
how do I how do I uh fix this problem
and with someone with a trained
professional I was able to really figure
things out that I wouldn't have thought
of myself therapy is so helpful for
learning positive coping skills and how
to set boundaries and empowers you to be
the best version of yourself it isn't
just for those who've experienced major
trauma if you're thinking about starting
therapy give better help a try it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get match with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge become
your own soulmate whether you're looking
for one or not visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10% off your first
month that's better help h lp.com
inside and we through you go to therapy
every week yeah I go basically every
week right right and do are you like me
where you're like I'm going to cancel I
have nothing to really talk about and
then you get in there and all of a
sudden it's the floodgates open yeah I
do cancel sometimes I
do sometimes the floodgates open but I
had my last recent one where I was like
I think I'm doing pretty well there's no
much to talk about and then I think even
she was bored like
just like I've done that I did this once
with a therapist it was about 40 minutes
and I go all right well my time's up
yeah so uh thank you you schedule
something else looking at the although
dude I had another session that I I sort
of you know I started doing standup
again and it sort of opened up some
interesting old patterns for me that we
can get into if you want to but it's
sort of like uh regarding anxiety and so
I was like I need to have like two or
three sessions with you in a row because
I need to figure out what's going on and
so the last session of that we were just
talking about it and I was sort sort of
talking about the strike and how it
can't work so I've had to do stand up
and she's like describe
yourself without using your profession
or your work or what you do and I had a
panic attack I was like she's like what
are you if you're not like an actor
comedian writer I was like I I don't
know it that's that's weird yeah right
so you can't associate yourself other
than who like who you are is what you do
I yeah man you don't have that issue I I
really I mean yes I mean to a point but
I've been working on it for like five
years where I just I kind of like took a
break from acting and I'm I'm starting
to get the bug back yeah because I've my
anxiety is at a better much better level
and I'm working on a lot of things but
um I think it was always about that I
think it was always about you know cuz
people think they say oh what are you
doing and you have you're compelled to
say oh well I've done them I'm doing I'm
doing that nothing is coming to fruition
but I got a lot of lot of lot of pant I
got a lot of things to stir SP a lot of
plates a lot of plates spinning but then
I'm like because I felt like they needed
to know I was important maybe or I felt
like I needed to be important and it's
and really it's about you know what
people say what are you doing now I go
you know what I swear to God this is
what I say now I
go I'm just trying to have fun yeah and
when I say that yeah it means fun with
everything I'm trying to have fun with
work I'm trying to have fun I want to be
present and fun with you I want to be
present and fun with my friends I want
to be present and fun when I'm writing
and if you know I'm thinking well what
if they hire a different uh you know uh
Rider and fire me I'm like I can't
control that that's the future just have
fun do what you can and whatever happens
happens dude that is I'm trying I'm
trying that's the key to everything and
and I'm trying too I mean you bring up
anxiety and I you know for me anxiety is
it's a constant I don't want to say
battle because it's not a battle but it
is a constant thing that you have to
work on like it's not like and now I
have no anxiety yeah anxiety comes back
you need to know how to how to
understand how to see it understand it
and and and deal with it but that [__]
what you said about control is so true
because for a long time I mean the last
few years of my career when I had a lot
more opportunities I found myself you
know it was it was after the big sick
and then suddenly you know I was getting
offers and I had never gotten that I had
fought to get like one scene in a movie
and suddenly I had all this stuff and I
realized that the way I was evaluating
what I wanted to do and what I didn't
want to do was all completely messed up
I was looking at like okay if I do this
this movie is going to come out in
theaters it's going to be a big hit then
I'll get more I was always results based
on my decision making um for those like
three years or so um and then I realized
you know I did stuff that should have
been a home run and then it wasn't like
eternals you know it's it's it was it
was uh Oscar winning director the one of
the craziest casts you know you had like
Legends you had Salma haak you had
Angelina Julie you had new people who
are amazing Brian Tyreek Henry Barry
kyogen who have both been nominated for
you thought it was just a slam dunk I
was like this is going to be a slam dunk
and it'll be great it'll open all the
stuff for me and going into it was great
for me cuz I was like I need to have fun
doing this movie and so I just and I did
and I was like I understand this movie
In My Bones I understand superheroes I
understand sci-fi I understand like
sci-fi epics and so I had the best time
doing that movie and I realized this is
what work should feel like however when
that movie came out and the reviews
weren't good that was very very tough
for me and I realized that too much of
how I'm evaluating what I want to do is
based on the result what other people
think of it me too my whole life was
that I I remember going you know doing a
movie and saying oh these people aren it
like you said and you know it's it's a
big studio and I remember even being so
obsessive is that the right word I think
with with each scene going okay this
scene I was really good in that's that
that's good that's going to be good this
scene you know I think I was good in
that I think in like evaluating every
scene yeah like that scene I wasn't
quite but I think it'll be okay cuz the
one before I was good in the one after I
was good so they'll Bridget yeah and
then you know they'll see this and then
this this should you know I should be
all projecting all the stuff that I my
therapist says if you can't control it
if you can't change it shove it yeah
shove the [__] just and what you're
saying is enjoying the ride yes one of
my friends said um he had a movie that
bombed I mean Rosen
bombed and he said um I go how do you
feel about it he goes
well I thought about it like this if I
was the young me and somebody says
you're going to be the lead actor in a
movie and you're going to direct the
movie yeah would you even be thinking
about and you're going to make money
yeah oh I me you wouldn't be thinking
about anything but just like this is
great this is fun
and there were moments on set where I
was having fun and enjoying in the
moment but we we can't control that and
the more I try to enjoy what I'm doing
the process yeah it it makes life so
much easier it does and it but it is a
constant you have to be intentional
about it you know so now I'm trying to
make decisions about what I do based on
like oh I love this actor this is a
small movie but I love this actor I want
to learn from them I want to watch how
this guy works so I'm going to do this
movie it movie may be great it may not
be great it may be a hit it may not be a
hit but I know that experience of
working with this guy is going to be
phenomenal like I did this movie stuber
years and years ago didn't do well but I
met Dave Batista and we're still like
really really good friends and it was
worth doing that movie from just like
that connection I made you know boy he's
blown up huh I love it too I text him
I'm like I'm so damn proud of cuz I
remember having convers ation even on
the pockets he's been on a couple times
and you
know when I saw
Guardians he was on Smallville years ago
I did not know that's how we met and um
one time I was at a a
convention and there was an announcement
Michael rosenbom Michael rosenbom can
you please go to the back somewhere and
I go yeah I'm about to leave on a plane
what what's going on they go hey Dave
Bautista really wants to say hello to
you and I go uh okay and I went over and
Dave's he's at a little private table or
whatever in the back he's doing like a
private signing or something I can't
remember but y Dave are you sure you you
want to see me yeah cuz I didn't really
he goes you didn't remember yeah man I
heard you were here and uh you were
always just so nice on set and I just
remember you're such a really good guy
and I just wanted to say hi Oh man and I
just go I love you yeah I love you wow
and then I saw him I think it was before
that when I saw him in Guardians and it
was really Guardians to his performance
I said this guy's special yeah he's not
just some wrestler who became an actor
he is working on it then I saw him in
knock at the cabin best part of the
movie was him yeah like he is
consistently working and he's you know
he works hard and I just I love it I
love seeing his success I mean I saw you
know what I sort of learn I'm always
like if I get to work with amazing
people what's my like takeaway and there
can be many and with him it was like oh
working hard is cool you know what I
mean like as a standup you know that's
how I started the whole thing of standup
at least the way we talked about it was
like working hard isn't cool you have to
like it has to be effortly it has to be
whatever I don't care that sort of
attitude was pretty big then when I was
starting out and that sort of seeped
into it even though I think in my bones
I'm a very hard worker but I didn't want
to present as that but with Dave and the
way he talks about acting in interviews
I was was like no I'm a hard worker and
I like talking about my work and I like
talking about how hard I work like I
really [__] love doing this and I
want to give it my best shot and so
working with Dave I really learned that
he's so good in um a Blade Runner too
which I think is I didn't see that oh my
do you like the original one people are
mixed on it okay I'm not really a Blade
Runner fan I mean it looks amazing but
I'm like H it's kind of boring see I
have a lot of patience for like uh like
the original Dune you probably liked
yeah I mean the original Dune is a wild
movie there's like you remember there's
like a huge I haven't read the books but
there's like a huge brain fish in it
that's like [__] weird looking and I
was like wow why is that not in the new
movie and they're like oh David Lynch
made that out that that wasn't in the
book that's not in the book and it's
like one of the best parts of the movies
is huge crazy Spina Joe our friend Joe
Spina he loves do the original J like
you're an idiot you don't know know what
you're talking about that's it I read I
read the book I I I this the original is
brilliant I like I like the new one yeah
I think the new one's fantastic but the
Blade Runner you know I have a lot of
room for like ponderous s he sci-fi so
the original Blade Runner I love it
because no movie to me feels like that
there's like a couple emotional beats in
it like when ruar Howard's giving his
like uh speech about as he's dying cuz
the whole thing is like are these
replicants human or not and then he
gives the speech about all the things
he's seen before he's dying and you're
like oh that answers that question they
can they can feel they're human I'm
getting emotional thinking about it in
high school I could I could recite that
whole speech cuz I thought that that
would get me laid and it did it doesn't
work doesn't work it does not work but
the new one I think what it does I'll
watch it it takes that world and it
gives it a real like narrative drive
like what you're saying the first one
you found boring I get that it's very
much like a tone poem but the new one
has a mystery uh at the center it really
works the story really works it looks
beautiful Harrison Ford's great in it
Ryan Gosling's great in it Batista's in
one scene he's great in it it's I think
it's a phenomenal movie when you talk
about eternals and it wasn't the
response that you were hoping how did
that affect you did it really consume
you for a while did it something you had
to get counseling on is it something
where you took it to heart like was it
was it me was it what was this I knew it
wasn't me um I think that there were a
lot of things that went into it I love
that movie I'm very proud of that movie
I'm proud of everyone's work in it and
and I'm proud of my work in it and I've
seen that movie you know um I've seen it
a bunch of times because it's like my
kind of movie um and I don't watch stuff
I'm in a lot and a lot of stuff I'm in
I've I've never watched um it was really
really hard because uh Marvel thought
thought that movie was going to be like
really really well reviewed and so they
lifted the Embargo really early and they
also put it in some fancy movie
festivals and they sent us on a big like
Global tour promoting the movie um right
as the Embargo was lifted and so we had
to like sort of travel the world while
they thought we'd be going on a wave of
raves you know and it wasn't true it
just sort of was the reviews were really
bad and you were aware of it while you
were on tour yeah I was too aware of it
I was too aware of it I was reading
every review I was checking too much
because this thing had become too much
in my head because this was also after
right after the pandemic you know so
we're coming out after this crazy thing
and I'm like okay this is going to be
the coming out party I worked so hard
for this and everything's heightened
your anxiety and life everything's kind
of like and now this happens everything
everything's heightened and um I don't
know I mean I think that there was some
weird soup in the atmosphere for why
that movie got slammed so much and I
think not very much of it has to do with
the actual quality of the movie anyway
it was really really hard and that's
when I was like this is unfair to me
it's unfair to Emily I can't approach my
work this way anymore some shit's got to
change and so very intentionally I did
start counseling I I I talked to I still
talk to my therapist about that I would
Emily says that you know obvious that
that that I do have Trauma from it I
actually Emily and I just got dinner
with someone else from that movie and we
were like man that was tough wasn't it
he's like yeah that was really tough I
think we all went through something kind
of similar and then this guy that I'm
talking about is has is like truly one
of the best actors of Our Generation and
has been nominated for an Oscar since
then um so I realized I can't be so
results based in my in my work anymore
cuz I can't really control it I can
control my experience I can control how
I am to the people around me I can
control what I learn from it I can
control how I work can't control what
people are going to think of it
no inside of you is brought to you by
discover if you like using debit over
credit don't you think it's time you
also get rewarded well now you can with
discover cashback debit it's a checking
account that rewards everyone with cash
back on everyday purchases plus there
are no fees period we're talking date
nights thrifting the latest trends
nights out with your friends and it's
now earning you cash back with discover
cashback debit check out eligibility and
terms at discover.com
slashback debit Discover Bank member
FDIC I I um on a smaller level uh you
know it was it was one of my first
probably it was my first movie really
and it was called Midnight in the Garden
of Good and Evil and it was with Clint
Ewood and I played one I had two scenes
but one was C I had one big scene is
that John cack yeah I had like a seven
minute scene in the courtroom and I
really love my performance and I really
like the movie and the script was a
bestseller John
Baron um I think that was right that was
a big movie but it it bombed and I was
like how am I in one of the only Clint
Eastwood movies to bomb how am I out of
all his movies like this would have been
a huge success more people and and it
just but
a few a few casting people saw the movie
and said I like this kid and it it
helped me out in ways but you know I was
like oh and then you know I did many
movies that I thought were going to be
and then they buried us or at the same
weekend came other movies out and then
then I look back and I go I really love
that movie and I really enjoyed doing it
and the process was really fun and and
that's what you got to like you can't
predict success no all you can do is
strive for it all you can do is enjoy it
yeah you really have to enjoy it we get
to live our dreams I mean it's it's can
you living our dreams we really are and
I know it's a tough industry and there's
a lot of [__] up about it and a lot of
it is based on how well things are doing
and how well things aren't doing but you
can't control that and just be happy for
the opportunities you have I mean this
all I say this it's still a struggle you
know I talk to my therapist about it a
lot I talked to Emily about it a lot and
does she go oh come on C I mean says I
have career dysmorphia which I think is
probably a little bit true um so I still
have like that thing of like the
underdog like I'll show them I'll show
them what I got yeah we all have that
now that's healthy I think it is healthy
I think that's a good thing well part of
the thing for me that I have to a little
bit what the chip on my shoulder about
that specific thing is I'm a brown guy
who's a comedy guy and so it's very easy
to get put into a certain kind of box
and then when you change the Box
suddenly you're in a different box and
you're like no the point is I don't want
to be I want to do [__] that I that like
really I want to really challenge myself
and learn and do [__] I've never done
before and it's hard because in this
business for the most part you are
looking for other people to like see
that in you to give you that shot
validate you and kind of give you yeah
yeah give you that shot you know and so
um to me that's that I just want to be
like all right what can I do now that's
like totally different from anything
I've done before or what can I do
combines a bunch of things that I've
been learning the last few years in a
new way yeah so I'm always that's sort
of how I try and make my decisions well
I think some people are you know they do
a part and you know they're good at that
part and they continue to do stuff like
that and they don't have a big range and
they get stuck sort of you know but with
you I think after you obviously proven
yourself dramatically and comically
comedically not comically comedically
really I'm not an English guy sometimes
comically sometimes comically You'
really done a good job uh yeah but I was
thinking about this when you're you know
striving to be a
comedian and going up every night and
putting yourself out there did you ever
seriously
think in the back of your head whether
it's ego or drive or
aspirations or perspirations like that
you wanted to become a serious actor
that you going to be a serious actor not
at all I didn't want to be an actor at
all I kind of fell into it I think what
helped me when I was doing standup was I
never had a big plan in mind it was
always just like the next step is what I
was looking for so when I was doing open
mics I was like I want to be booked on a
show and when I was booked on a show I
was like oh I want to be booked on the
road outside of Chicago and when I did
that I was like well I don't want to
host I want to feature now I want to go
from doing 10 minutes to 20 minutes see
but that's Health you look at that back
then you were going from step to step
you weren't jumping steps exactly I want
to be huge I want to have my own Netflix
show and there were certainly people who
thought like that and then who did get
that you know but I never had a Grand
Vision I just love doing standup and I
wanted to write funny jokes and I wanted
to do well and each time try and like
take a little bit step forward and it
sort of hurt me a little bit because I
started I was in Chicago for six years
which is too long I should have I mean
I'm it's fine now but I should have
stayed there two or three years but
because I was just I sort of got stuck
in a rut a little bit and part of it was
because I didn't have a any kind of like
Grand aspiration so I sort of fell into
it I fell into acting but when I look
back you know my favorite like um like
Robin Williams is one of my favorites
right and who's funnier than him and
who's I don't think there's there's any
I can't think of a standup comedian
who's pivoted to Serious acting um as
successfully as he has while still doing
comedy like he was kind of going back
and forth but his like series
performances are so good and so varied
you know so as in my uncle always says
Robin Williams puts on a beard when he's
serious yeah good he puts on that
Goodwill Hunting beard put the Goodwill
Hunting beard on you're serious but go
ahead there's a monologue he has in it
where he's talking to um Matt Damon you
see go
ahead you're you can do Impressions I
don't do Robin Williams but I'd like to
I could hear I could see you I could see
his mannerisms I bet if I worked it I
could do it go ahead some people have
the ear for it and you I could do a lot
of Impressions but not I don't I've
never tried oh that thing um
yeah um yeah he gives this monologue
about you know it's a f very famous one
when he's in the park and he's talking
to Good Will Hunting and he's sort of
like you know you know all these things
like youve read Shakespeare but you've
never been in a war you've never seen
your buddy like Die In Your Arms you
could like quote sonnets about love but
you've never watched your loved one die
of cancer I'm getting emotional talking
about it oh wow is this really like it's
like a seven minute monologue and the
first five minutes are just on Robin
Williams face see how that affects I
could see the tears in your eyes that
really still lingers with you that
performance you just channeled it God
it's so openhearted that performance and
and what it's it's it's yeah it's hardly
a performance because it just feels like
he's just telling the truth oh and it's
so magical and it's so interesting cuz
he can do that which is very natural and
very like openhearted and then he can
also do Genie and Aladdin which is very
much a performance yeah it's so it's
he's brilliant he really is brilliant I
think one that you compare to but I uh a
lot of people will say I'm kind of weird
is Jim Carrey yeah Jim car at times
there's been moments in Jim car's career
that I'm like wow yeah that was pretty
impressive well Jim Carrie I think when
he was in his like Comedy Zone I don't
think there was ever been any comedic
actor who's beaten that when he was like
you know the Ace
Ventura the mask I saw the mask again
recently hold up yeah and you forget
that it's mostly just him in a green in
a green like in green makeup it feels CG
but you're watching you're like oh no
he's just doing that he's moving his
body like that he's unbelievable
obviously the special effect the best
physical comedian there ever was I mean
you think of uh who's the you know
Buster Keaton and and Charlie Chaplan
but like so different right they're so
understated yes oh they're brilliant
they're they're about the tension
between their body and their face
whereas Jim car is really the whole
thing andity and then Eternal Sunshine
is such a magical one of those perfect
how about uh what What's the other one
uh where he plays cman oh man on the
moon I've never seen that oh I love man
on the moon did you see that no you
don't have a mic sorry um but you were
going back to um you know the comedian
and being a comedian and taking
everything step by step and like being
this so you never had that in your mind
to be a serious actor when did you
realize and you there was a moment where
you realized I'm good I'm really good
well something's happening I'm good I
don't know I feel I'm trying to I mean I
still don't have I mean you know I
really feel like I'm I'm learning I
really am learning and I can feel I know
the things that I I don't know that's a
hard question to answer do you know
you're good at least do you go you know
I I I know I'm good without being ego
like people tell you but you go I must
be doing something right obviously I do
know and I know when I'm good and I know
when I'm not quite as good and and even
if other people can't tell I can tell
and I know I can do more that I haven't
shown yet and that I haven't learned yet
like I will sometimes I'll watch a movie
and I'll watch like a really really
great performance you know and I'll be
like I want to be able to do that I
think I could I'd have to work and
really you know but I'm like I that I
want to try and do that I've done that
where I look at someone and I go there's
three ways maybe two I'm just spit
allall in here but the first way is
first thing is I see some performance
and I go I could never do that I totally
that is absolutely Beyond the realm of
my capabilities a lot of like Jim Cary
Robin Williams those like comedic
perform just certain performances that
like yeah exactly and then there's
sometimes where I
go I could I could do that yeah I could
really do that like I'll be honest with
you um it's not that I would be better
it's not that I would you know for
instance breaking bad but okay to say
that you would be better no but Breaking
Bad Brian Cranston I watch and I go he's
[__] phenomenal could I do better no
could I play a part like that [__] yeah
how awesome is that I would [__] love
to play that the ju's the position of
good and bad and like yeah and just kind
of comical at times and stuff I would
[__] I know I could do that I know
from the work I put in in my life I
could do it and what a great feeling but
I'm not saying I'm better than him or
anything I'm just saying I could play a
part like that yeah you know what I mean
yeah and that's how you feel right um
yeah sometimes you know the hardest one
and this is me being petty is when you
watch a big thing and someone in a big
thing and you're
like I could be better than that yeah
yeah oh yeah oh yeah and I'm not talking
actors at the level of Brian Cranston
you know no but I do that but I go like
this I go I could [__] I could do so
much better than this dude and then I go
but he's so much better looking than I
mean that's usually that's what I
usually say that's part of it isn't it
so much hotter there's also actors who I
find like I certainly have my opinion on
actors and acting and and there are
certain actors where I'm like um
everyone loves them and I'm like I could
see all the choices you're making I
could like with that I can see your
script right now and what notes you've
written on the side you Circle that yeah
and I could see every like pivot you're
doing to me the real magic which I
aspire to is the I don't know how that
happened and I I think there was like
maybe one take where you did that or or
someone like Jack Nicholson who could do
take after take from what you read that
is just as good and when you watch it
there's no seams there's no like
decisions or choices it's him just
living expressing I think that comes
back to what you said before to be able
to be really relaxed and confident in
what you're doing knowing that you can
do it and just being because there are
actors who I call mirror actors who look
in the mirror oh the night before and do
the scene to the Mirror and this is the
one way and the only way they're going
to do it not taking account in account
the other people because acting is
listening so when you're talking to an
actor your response could be different
every time depending on how they respond
to you like I'm responding to you that's
all of it that's that to me is all of
acting and you have to be prepared to be
malleable yeah you must be uh present
like I'm trying to do in life but I've
worked with actors I've worked with both
kinds of actors I've worked with actors
who are in a bubble where you start
working with them and you're like oh
you've decided you've got some Target
you're trying to hit and each take
you're trying to hit that Target and I
see what decisions you're making between
takes and I'm also seeing what notes
you're getting and how you're taking
those notes you know um those actors
sometimes when you watch them you know
most people can't tell there's big
actors who work like that big very
successful actors but when you're
working with them it's not that exciting
what is really exciting is when you like
I don't know what you're going to do but
it's going to change what I'm going to
do and that's going to change what
you're going to do and every take's
going to be different when we did the
big sick worked with Holly Hunter right
who's like one of the greats one of the
greats every take all 28 Days of our
shoot or 26 Days of our shoot no it was
like a five-week shoot every take was
completely different there's a big scene
in it where her and Ray Romano who plays
her husband have this big argument in
the hospital and it's like everyone's
got to be there you know yeah every
they're like they can't like really yell
at each other it's in the waiting room
right it's in the waiting room yeah one
thing was interesting was they so her
and Ray rehears that on set and they'd
rehearsed already on their own 14 times
cuz they're blocking it as they're going
and I'm also a producer on the movie so
I'm like [__] we're going to go to
lunch what are we going to do so 14
takes we do uh 14 rehearsals literally
and then Holly's like all right let's
shoot cuz the whole time we're like
let's [__] shoot you guys are so good
let's
shoot okay let's shoot and the ad0 goes
rolling and She lays down on the floor
of this hospital that's a real hospital
and closes her eyes and everyone's just
like silently like looking at this it's
completely quiet and she's just laying
in the middle of the like holy [__] what
is she doing what is going on and I
guess the and then the ID is like cut I
guess and for like 5 minutes She lays
there completely still and then she
wakes up and she's like all right let's
shoot and then they do three takes each
take is completely different and she
crushes it and Ray crushes it and it's
great and three we make our we make our
day you know and then wow that was like
one of the first days of shooting so
then a week later now I've gotten to
know her we're shooting the scene in the
middle of the night where we have to eat
and I was like I got to ask you when you
lay down in the middle of the floor what
were you doing and she said I was just
relaxing she was just forgetting
everything you know what I think that's
so important I don't think we tell
ourselves or allow ourselves to relax
before things we all intense camera's
rolling uh makeup there all right makeup
out
you got to take your moment yeah you
take it actor's ready give me give me
give me a minute please yeah take your
moment get in the zone breathe do
whatever it takes I remember Quinton
Tarantino I watched this interview and I
don't think anybody else has ever seen
this interview but it was like it was on
TV and he
goes the the interviewer says what do
you like with actors what do you what
kind of advice would you give actors or
something he goes up excuse me could you
could you uh zoom in you zoom in my face
and the camera guy Zooms in on him he
goes listen you guys don't know how much
power you
have in an audition it's your time you
guys it's yours you're bringing whatever
it is and he goes off on this thing it's
like this is and he filled me with
confidence like this is you this is your
power this is your time to shine you do
what you want yeah and you know and he
goes on about that and I was just like
holy [__] like when you can actually
relax and and you're more capable I
think of doing the things you want to do
you really are and I had this the stup
two two things one little quick thing
when I was doing Chi andales you know I
was working with Anna Ashford who's like
one of the best actors I've ever worked
with and every take is different and
exciting I love that there's a part
where we have this fight with each other
and after a few takes I was kind of just
feeling a little bit stuck and I didn't
know what to do and she's so good and I
was feeling a little bit stuck and I was
like all right I'm just going to in
between takes I'm just going to touch
this table and I'm just going to really
feel what this table feels like I
touched the table and I almost started
crying cuz I had like sort of gotten
locked down or stuck or whatever and in
my head and you just really like that
got me present immediately yeah the
other thing I've noticed is you know
I've started doing standup again during
these strikes so I've been doing it
about a month and a half now and um it's
interesting cuz I've learned cuz I had
never learned to relax during standup it
was always like really tight and go and
I was found myself defaulting into that
mode when I started doing standup again
because it's the same like uh body
memory you know you're like walk out the
feeling of the mic looking at all the
people with anticipation the clap the
the the the the Clapping going down
you're like feel little bit of sweat on
your temple what does that mean I'm
going to pass out all that stuff yeah
and I this last week and a half you know
I do the alt shows I do Largo and those
crowds know me and I can sort of be very
loose and it's fun but I've also been
doing the club so I've been done the
Hollywood improv and have done The
Comedy Store a whole bunch and those
places they really want you to do tight
jokes and they really are uh you know
it's a lot of tourists and stuff so you
really got to go and hit them and so I
said all right when I do these clubs I
would get so [__] nervous and I was
like I'm just not going to be nervous
and I'm going to meditate right before I
go on stage so it's the opposite instead
of going out being like I got to grab
him by the throat and kill it's the
opposite I'm not going to kill I'm just
going to go on stage and be completely
relaxed and see what happens you're like
a python yeah just
slowly slowly kill him slow and it's the
reaction has been so much better for the
first time at like The Comedy Store I've
I've been like I've been having like
great sets cuz I go out and I'm like all
right let's see let's see how this goes
and really lean back and it's been
really it's been a great lesson in
exactly what you're saying which is like
relaxing look at what that says there
just relax look at that yeah look
perfect that's your Vantage Point is
perfect Vantage Point remember that what
makes you happy what makes me happy
that's a big
answer but really the thing I love doing
most is spending time with Emily me and
her a come on you made me cry now
genuinely like at home watching movies
playing video games or what I really
love is me and her are going to a
restaurant like and just eating and just
having a Just the Two of Us for hours
that's my favorite thing to do I I
honestly I'm not just saying this I love
her she's the greatest I love her I
really get to hang out with her the
first time at James's wedding James
gun's wedding name drop but and then
just hanging out with her here
she's just so funny she and she's so
genuine it's like unbelievable she just
the you know I it's amazing how like
it's 16 years and you guys been together
it's not amazing because I see you
together and it's just like what I see
is that you each you you both just let
each other have their moment and just do
their thing and just let them be who
they are she's one of those magic people
like truly and and I say that to her and
she's like oh you just love me I'm like
I do love you but everyone else sees it
too yeah people see she has that thing
where people immediately connect with
her and she's so [__] funny she'll
just say things that I'm like or she'll
say something really profound and I'm
like Poetic I'm like where's that from
she's like oh I just said it I'm like
write that down so she has a document of
just stuff she just randomly says to me
that I'm like write that down cuz she
just has she was a therapist you know so
she has this like she understands people
and loves people so much and it's also
just really funny and really insightful
and she's one of those one of those
people I I got a book idea for you it's
called Emily writes stuff down and it's
a book of all the things she's written
down over the years profound poignant
funny ridiculous yeah you know I'm
trying to think what she said just
yesterday that I was like that's like
two words but I think there's no better
combination of two words in this context
that right now I'd have to like look
through my text but she's just so I'll
be like what what's what is you is that
is that you know who quoted that I'm
like I I just said it is that anything
I'm like yeah that's like the coolest
thing I've heard in weeks you know it
sounds like uh we talk about listening
is the most important thing obviously in
acting yeah but I I I I'm not married
I'm single I'm you know I'm figuring it
out just that's all I'll say but would
you say that that's the number one thing
in a marriage to keep it healthy it's
the hardest it's the it's going to sound
the most Pat and the most like but the
the most like cliche communication there
is nothing listening and and telling
each other what's really going on inside
that's the most important thing
genuinely because for a long time I
would keep stuff from her like I mean
like I have a job coming up I'm scared
I'm nervous what if I can't do this what
if I'm not good enough I just keep that
inside cuz if I say it it becomes real I
found if I just say it to her like hey
just so you know I'm scared about this
thing thing coming up I don't know if I
can do it it actually takes its power
away um and so really telling each other
what's going on inside by far the
biggest breakthrough we've had in our
marriage is that and it sounds so um
like it sounds cliche like I said but
you really have to be intentional about
it there was a time where we were like
every day both of us have to say three
things to each other we were in this was
when we we went to Coupes therapy three
things to each other that are vulnerable
genuinely vulnerable and so we did that
exercise for a few weeks and it was
[__]
great vulnerable yeah I I of course
think of the me saying that to someone
yeah I immediately thought of like what
would I say every day three new things
that they can be big things or small
things you know sorry about premature
ejaculation yeah sure that's
embarrassing that's vulnerable it is
[Music]
um
sorry
for always crying during movies do you
cry during movies no but you do I do
I've started to no I I do cry I I do cry
I get emotional I get emotional when it
reflects something that's happened in my
life or it's parallel to things that I
have witnessed as a child or as an adult
and I can relate or victims or whatever
or people in general when it's real it
can be pretty visceral
yeah I mean that's the magic of what we
get to do right like when it's good you
really have you're like people can see
themselves you know Emily says that she
does what she does because she wants to
make people feel less lonely because
loneliness comes from not sharing
yourself you know and wow and and you
see people going through the same things
you go through look at this and you
realize oh we have a visitor I but
finish that that was an important that
what a beautiful oh go go Sayo come out
hi hi how beautiful how beautiful are
you hi
baby
he all right get out guys get out get
out come on in the middle of an
interview how unprofessional hi the
blanch is my beauty she's five look at
this guy oh my God you know what this is
a great way to end the
interview I mean there's no better way I
me you have to you can plan and stuff
and then suddenly you can't plan this
beautiful dogs you're a beautiful man
this has been a real treat you come back
again sometime of course this so easy
it's so easy you're so open yeah I love
you I love you buddy all right
bye what else can you say about the
guy I mean funny smart talented he's the
real he's all the things he's the real
deal that was a cool one he's one of
those guys that I've been watching for a
long time so was cool to see him in the
flesh and cool that he's you know a good
good Soul a good egg he's really a good
egg I've had some good conversations
with him and he's just got a big heart
and a dark sense of humor too which I
love yeah I like that you can just talk
you know how his mind works it's uh you
know you could say something so really
funny and dark and then say something so
beautiful at the same time and Emily is
a genius he his wife I freaking love her
she's uh she and I have some good laughs
uh thank you for for listening to that
and make sure you follow us on our
handles and all that at inside of you
podcast on Instagram and Facebook at
inside you pod on the Twitter and
support the podcast um go to patreon.com
inside you and join today and you can
give back um you guys keep the show
alive so whether it's a dollar a month
or $5 dollar whatever it is um but the
top tiers here give a lot and they get
their names wrote out and other stuff so
we're going to jump into that now we're
going to do the top tier podcast shout
outs top tier patrons I I love these
guys and I love all my patrons so let's
let's just do that patreon.com inside
you let's go why don't you lead us off
with old Nancy D Nancy D Leah and
Christen little Lisa Yukiko Jill e Brian
h niik p Robert B Jason W Sophie M Raj C
Jennifer N Stacy L Jamal epin lb yes
we're doing a YouTube live so uh make
sure you guys get on that and my YouTube
YouTube live is next week and then we're
going to I'm going to schedule a zoom
with the top tier patrons so you guys be
aware of that and also if you send
messages I know on Google I don't check
them often but um I I appreciate them
sometimes they're so long I can't really
respond I just I but I do look at them
and I do appreciate it if I don't
respond you know I still do look at them
so um it's just hard to respond to
everybody I get so many messages and I
appreciate you Mikey yon Supremo 99 more
hello Dan hello 99 more Santiago M I
can't wait till glver gets a statue lean
p matd s Belinda
andh Sheila G Brad d Ray H tabi the T
Tom in tal M Betsy D Ranna C Corey K Dev
Nexon Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy D
Eugene and Leah Cory Mel s Christine s
Eric H Shane R Andrew M Oracle Amanda R
Kevin e Stephanie K Jor L jamond J lean
J and Luna R Mike F Stonehenge Brian l
Jules M Kendall L Jessica
B Kyle no that was still me all right
whatever I know it was slow Kyle I was
thinking of an impression Kyle F Kaylee
Kaylee J Brian a Marian Louise L Romeo
the band Frank B Jen T Nikki L April RM
Randy s jdw orl p or h d Laurel L
Melissa H Laurel laurelai laurelai Nick
W Stephanie and Evan Charlene a d g
Jenny B
John it's just John just John John it's
not just John it's John joh it's not
John it's
John everybody it's
John John well John Jennifer R Tina e NG
Tracy juny jun's relatively new and
Tasha
s that's some newbies I I I I love that
people are like you know sometimes I
look and I'm oh my gosh I have another
top tier or another Patron and I try to
send messages and stuff so it's cool
patreon.com inside you um thank you for
listening as always we'll try to bring
you the best guests we can and give you
the best conversations and hopefully it
will help and hopefully you'll enjoy it
and uh thank you from uh the Hollywood
Hills and Hollywood California I am
Michael rosenbom I'm Ryan Tails we're
doing this voice again yes we are way to
the camera thank you guys always I love
you and uh just be good to yourself I'll
see
[Music]
you